it públicos food-eating in the in terms
of the KKK Jews is number one
Jews number 1 I say to African American
Jews number 1 during a lot of lists yeah
they're on a little outlets but um Jews
African Americans third is probably not
you know what a Muslim middle-eastern I
think they're second a religious yeah
yeah I think that they were probably
number two and then African rivers are
three the for Latinos for Shore Xuan and
five there's not a lot I think you break
up the Asians because I think they're
okay with the lighter skinned Asians
because they don't know the difference
between an Indian and someone from the
Middle East
oh they don't yeah yeah so Indians are
fifth and then we're probably six
mornings at HS or seven no Filipinos are
basically like we're basically black
we're in we're basically black in
Mexicans we're a mix between but if
there was a race war right now and and
minority is collectively outnumber
whites now right if you put yeah yeah
you do we do in all of America I think
in case yeah in all of America dude in
California whites are definitely the
minority yeah California are they mm-hmm
I mean just overall like they've been
out and they're not they don't make up
the the majority but it's okay but
listen but in a in a race war let's just
suppose it's cut down the line 5050 I'm
joining with Mexicans
no but what I'm saying I think that
white people would still win that war
because they have access to weapons that
we don't what yeah the government who's
in America in America okay you know race
war in America sessions Albright and and
we were just white people just we're
forced to be in war with minorities we
would have crazy people I mean I would
feel pretty good with the art side we
have the Latin gangs like mmm okay
yeah we still get the Bloods and Cripps
yeah we still got we still got some good
people yeah I got to what they have they
have Halliburton they have access to the
military probably Rothschild what's
rough so the big banks yeah they have a
lot of things in my gonna have so I
think that would be a really bloody of
war ya know it's a word that I don't
want to see you also have a system set
up to keep minorities down so of course
we'd lose we're already losing with even
without the war it'll radio war because
that na doc yo bro so that now walk Oh
God actually sounded urban and Asian
dellwo that wall that wall was we hide
hide
it'd be difficult because we would that
would not be that would be a two hundred
year war we'd we would go guerrilla
warfare guerrilla war no uniforms you
don't know where we're coming from
well they know who we are by their faces
but here's where I find interesting okay
yeah because you're saying if there was
a race war I really do think we would at
least recruit seventy five percent of
the white people in America believe it
or not no but let's in the rule you
can't recruit what I mean it's just down
the line George is in a race for some
reason came down and just put it in the
minds of all whites like again yeah then
you have to kill these minorities mmm
right so it's split down the middle
there's no recruiting all right
brainwash you because then like we could
just they would get the whites would get
a bunch of fat white chicks to recruit
black people so then yeah so and then
we'd be like oh [ __ ] weird look on yeah
we're dead yeah so right that's right
yeah
first you're headed she is like yo
nature where you going yeah man switch
the size he was neat row
means each HR means from the San Diego
Chargers I like that name nature nature
I try yeah great now yeah awesome think
I like fat [ __ ] of that you know
whatever and then he's gone and then we
would they would public at sugary drinks
and tits to steal the Mexicans yeah
what's the Asian bait here's fermented
stuff yeah fermenting no I'll tell you
why we don't have a bit yeah because
that remember that Japanese soldier who
was in the Philippines for forty years
he thought that the war was still going
on oh yeah and war to store any lived 40
years he killed a bunch of Filipinos
yeah and he refused to let the [ __ ]
wartime what well I don't know what this
you didn't know that the war was over he
had been living I select a hermit but in
like a cave so he was just doing
guerrilla warfare yes yeah by himself
and then one day I think somebody
convinced him that the war's over forty
years later he was okay
any went back to yeah they let him go
after that after well yeah I don't not
sure your stories my point I did not
know okay bye half our country by
yourself yeah yeah it is during warfare
it's okay so maybe yeah I mean there's a
good chance it's probably true George I
have heard some version of this story
but I don't know of his that's just like
the Philippine version would have an
urban myth that like gets passed along
because it's such a great story the
Japanese now [ __ ] up well what I
Google Google Bobby's the words that I
put Japanese World War two Philippines
no just put Japanese soldier cave oh
[ __ ] Wow also he's his middle finger for
every here we go his name is Huell Huell
nada nada bro write it her Oh nada or
here we go was an imperial japanese army
intelligence officer
who
fought in World War two and was a
Japanese holdout who did not surrender
in 1945 after anata spent 29 years 29
years holding out in the Philippines his
former commander traveled from Japan to
personally issue orders relieving him
from duty in 1974 why they take that
long I don't know find him but it was a
long time sweetie am i right
yes you're right you're apologizing
apologize I'm sorry you win this time
sir yeah I know I did
he's a handsome man though but did he
end up killing people still he killed a
couple of Filipinos oh my and it took
that long 29 years for chebet Japan to
be like hey let's go find that guy
it also had to get them you know he had
to get the the Admiral his his his song
as you know superior because it had to
be above him he wouldn't listen to
listen or yeah we're not crazy
yeah so that's why in a race war I don't
think Asian would surrender we just keep
going I think this if you fed me this
right here which is a mango pineapple
hybrid yeah oh that would date me and
all day long you're a [ __ ] traitor I
know I make a stealthy what would be
your weird how dare you
if okay if George had my hunger you I
swear using it can slowly bethe bull guy
eat yeah we could still eat like what's
the true deep thing where it's like oh
that's what's gonna trigger me to jump
besides oh my god if you saw George
walking the white flag and he said
here's the only way they could do it you
know they wouldn't get you to the up
front okay we because minorities would
take over la yeah yeah I think we would
drive the white stronghold coming strong
for New York - so we're here it's like
escape from New York it's barricaded and
then the whites turned off the power and
it can no longer play video games I see
right okay we're disconnected my Wi-Fi
I'd say like you know
so first the world [ __ ] I gotta play
destiny so then I would probably go over
take that destiny knowledge
to the real world yeah that is you just
be like think about what's the next gun
I can get yeah I don't think I can
actually shoot a person if you saw
George and the opposing line and you
know for all that George has done for us
would you be able to kill him
yes yes I wouldn't do it only if he
tried to kill me but I would try to talk
it out yeah that's some Civil War [ __ ]
there yeah yeah I'd be like bye do you
know what I would do first get my
partner payoff okay how about this how
about this I don't find out I find out
so we're in LA I find that the whites
have snuck into you know like at the
canyon somewhere in the kapenga Canyon
so that's our what that's the white
stronghold a hippie stronghold to land
right and he and my general said to me
and my brother and Gilbert you guys have
to like hunt them down psycho and we see
George by the way who's our general a
minority it's a Delroy Lindo okay that's
a good choice yeah Laurie Lindo yeah
Delroy Lindo tells us and then we go and
we see George and he he's lost we have
machine guns he's scavenging for bears
it's you know what would happen Steve
would hug them I know it videos are
coming out and then we're [ __ ] up
Steve yeah yeah good get back and I'd
have to go up to him and go what's up
man let's just play it out what's up man
all right hey Bobby hey George how are
you good I got like three wild
blueberries here and whatever whatever
Tamara wouldn't give you shut the [ __ ]
up I'm supposed to kill you and I'm
gonna let you go so I'm gonna turn
around I'm gonna close my eyes I'm gonna
count to 20 yeah and you better be gone
there's exact George yeah yeah oh I'm
running you would you run oh hell yeah
but you know what I would say to you
before that before Iran hey if the
circumstances were different
I Love You Man one two three even if
you're running bang bang no word shoots
Georgian delay that was for Jessica yeah
that's not thing about that resource
yeah it's also 2017 is never gonna
happen
never although I have besides I don't
like being a not being able to switch
sides
[Music]